i'm excited to share this animation with
you all because i think it is
beautifully done it's so so good so i'm
gonna pop it here on the screen so that
we can watch together and throughout the
video i'll be pausing it commenting
describing stuff so let's start
a cesarean section often referred to as
a c-section is a surgical procedure in
which incisions are made in a woman's
abdomen and uterus to deliver a baby
some cesarean sections are planned more
i know i'm an ob gyn so i deal with
pregnancy literally every single day of
my life i've done hundreds and hundreds
of c-sections
just seeing this is so amazing it's
amazing what a woman's body goes through
all of the changes how big the uterus
gets how you form a placenta that
supports this pregnancy and feeds this
baby oxygen and nutrients
forever fascinated often however the
need for the procedure becomes apparent
after the onset of labor when abnormal
conditions make a vaginal delivery
unsafe for the mother or her baby
common indications for cesarean section
include so i think this is a good time
to talk about the fact that overall a
vaginal delivery across the board is
usually what's going to be best for the
mom and the baby and having a vaginal
delivery should always be the goal but
that does mean that there are some
medical conditions where a c-section is
what's going to be necessary and what's
going to be best so i am very thankful
that we do have c-sections because there
are conditions where it's just simply
unsafe to have a vaginal delivery for
the mom or for the baby let's go over
the indications dystocia placenta previa
and fetal
distress dystocia or prolonged
non-progressive labor can occur when the
baby's head is unable to fit through the
birth canal or its body is in an
unfavorable position
such as perpendicular to the birth canal
or buttocks first which is the breech
position
placenta previa occurs when a low-lying
placenta partially or completely blocks
the cervical opening quickly what it
means to have a placenta previa if you
have the cervix and then you have the
placenta sitting on top and then the
baby on this side
you cannot start dilating your cervix
because the placenta cannot deliver
first that would be detrimental to the
pregnancy and to the baby fetal distress
occurs whenever the health of the baby
is in imminent danger
usually from inadequate blood flow
through the placenta or umbilical cord
fetal distress can occur when the
placenta separates from the wall of the
uterus
prior to now this graphic that we're
about to watch the narrator talks about
when the placenta starts to separate
from the wall of the uterus this is
what's called a placental abruption and
this is an indication in most cases for
a c-section as that placenta starts to
detach from the uterus it's not getting
enough blood and if the placenta isn't
getting enough blood the baby's not
getting enough blood delivery or the
umbilical cord becomes compressed or
squeezed
other conditions that may require a
cesarean section include
large tumors of the uterus
genital herpes or other infections
or medical problems such as uncontrolled
diabetes or hypertension your doctor may
use ultrasound testing and a fetal heart
monitor to help decide whether your baby
should be delivered by cesarean
when a cesarean section becomes
necessary you will be prepped for
surgery
if not already in place an intravenous
line will be started and a catheter will
be inserted into your bladder to drain
urine
in the operating room you will be given
anesthesia
in most cases a spinal anaesthetic is
administered to numb the lower portion
of your body
sometimes however a general anesthetic
will be used i love that this video is
explaining everything we're able to see
what you expect before the procedure and
i think now we're going to see what to
expect during the procedure
your doctor will begin by making an
incision in your abdomen it will either
be a vertical incision from just below
the navel to the top of the pubic bone
or more frequently a horizontal incision
across and just above the pubic bone
this is often called a bikini cut
your doctor will then make a second
incision on the lower part of the uterus
once the uterus is opened your doctor
will rupture the amniotic sac if it is
still intact and deliver the baby
the time from the initial abdominal
incision to birth is typically fine this
is an amazing graphic so as you can tell
from the graphic the feet delivered
first so this is the c-section that's
being done for a breech baby doctor will
then clamp and cut the ability you know
that it is still recommended to do
delayed cord clamping even during a
c-section so long as the baby is what we
call vigorous breathing on its own
crying wiggling around and looks overall
healthy it is still recommended to do
delayed cord clamping for 60 seconds
gently remove the placenta
and tightly suture your uterus and
abdomen this typically takes about 45
minutes now let's watch their tips for
after the procedure the hospital stay
after a cesarean section is usually
three to five days during this time you
will be encouraged to breastfeed
nap when the baby sleeps and get out of
bed often while most patients are able
to take care of their new baby soon
after the procedure
full recovery may take six to eight
weeks your scar will lighten as it heals
always important to follow closely with
your doctor to make sure you're meeting
all of those milestones after the
surgery all right so that brings us to
the end of the animation wasn't that
amazing i thought that was so cool man
this company did such a good job i'm a
visual person so to actually get to see
something like that
so so cool i hope you all enjoyed this
video i loved getting to go through this
animation with you all i know i'm biased
because i'm an ob gyn but i truly do
think c-sections are such an amazing
surgery and i honestly feel so honored
and so blessed that i get to bring life
into this world whether it's by a
vaginal delivery or a c-section this
video was a collaboration between
nucleus medical media and the allyrodmd
youtube channel where i have created a
fun space to talk about all things
related to women's health please check
out my youtube channel by visiting the
link in the description below thank you
so much for watching this amazing
animation with me i love getting to talk
about c-sections and pregnancy with you
all i truly hope you enjoyed it as
always remember to be kind and show love
to everyone around you i hope you guys
have an amazing week bye